am freitag besuchen
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
und wirtschaftsministerin margarete
schramböck lehrlings testungen in der
hessen kaserne in wels insgesamt fast
900 bewerberinnen und bewerber bewerben
sich für 120 lehrlings plätze beim
österreichischen bundesheer also wir
freuen uns wirklich sehr dass wir in 36
verschiedenen lehrberufen junge menschen
ausbilden ausbilden dürfen
das ist gerade in dieser zeit sehr
wichtig das österreichische bundesheer
wird wahrgenommen als sicherer
ausbildner und dienstgeber und das freut
mich wirklich besonders
wirtschaftsministerium margarete
schramböck betont die vielfältigen
ausbildungsmöglichkeiten beim bundesheer
es gibt ganz historische lehrberufe die
sonst nirgends mehr gibt aber noch viel
wichtiger es gibt ganz moderne
lehrberufe zum beispiel coding man kann
hier programmieren lernen
man kann hier in die flugzeugtechnik
einsteigen oder auch in den maschinenbau
in alle unterschiedlichen lehrberufe und
das schöne daran es junge frauen
bewerben sich genauso wie junge männer
wenn man als lehrling beim bundesheer
die ausbildung absolviert heißt das aber
nicht dass man danach auch beim
bundesheer bleiben die einen wollen
dabei bleiben und um die werben wir auch
auf entsprechende art und weise sind ja
sehr viele berufe die bei uns
ausgebildet werden das sonst überhaupt
nirgends mehr gibt wenn man nur das
beispiel des sattlers oder auch des
buchdruckers denkt und wir werben dass
die jungen menschen bei uns bleiben wir
testen sie ja nicht nur bilden sie aus
sondern wir begleiten sie auch während
dieser phase und bereiten sie danach
allfällige bewerbungsgespräche vor die
auch außerhalb des buches jahr sind aber
erstes ziel ist natürlich dass
diejenigen die bei uns ausgebildet
worden sind auch bei uns bleiben
die daumen und ich hoffe dass ich dann
sehr viele von handwerk und wendig alles
alles alles gute